when mario draghi hotfoots it through
parliament it has something of an
economic state of the union address
about it one with news of modest growth
in europe but also dismal unemployment
figures euro-area economic activity
should continue its slow recovery
however
unemployment in the euro area remains
far too high this though was a briefing
for meps on new tools of crisis
avoidance and management which come
under banking union like an early
warning banking surveillance system or a
europe-wide bank resolution system
designed to support shaky banks without
burden to the taxpayer
europe has reinforced fiscal and
macroeconomic surveillance
created a permanent crisis management
mechanism there were reservations though
particularly over the heavy demands
placed on bailout countries
with youth unemployment high especially
in europe south mrs ferreira is
concerned only the stronger countries
benefit from europe's upturn i think we
have got also to create some sort of
growth inside europe if you don't have
any mechanisms that will help these
countries to produce a bit of
of of income you will never be able to
pay back what you borrowed there was
concern too that without the uk the
bank's supervisory mechanism could not
be as effective as it might
not be
the european
right now though meps want this first
stage of banking union to advance
quickly arguing it's a key to continue
stabilizing the national and european
economies